eu vou falar do vôo do rio e ele
e ele ah ah ah
isto porque no trecho que ouviram
gravado em condições precárias
representa no imaginário do do povo do
planalto central angolano algo que tem
uma mensagem muito profunda
o lyon de uma cegonha amiga voa alto não
cante bamba é um pássaro que se arrastar
pelo chão ea tradução do que estava
escrito e um fundo da canção com bianca
e ela aprender com aquele catimba fala
por si
isto significa meu ombro vantagem voa
não faz com catimba que fica na sua
produção
esta canção inspirou um grupo de
angolanos que nos anos 90 decidiram
criar uma organização uma associação que
chamo adra ação para o desenvolvimento
rural e ambiente era mais do que uma
agência implementadora do project era
uma associação que tentava apresentar a
diversidade do povo angolano em termos
dos seus membros e estávamos numa altura
em que já se falava da democracia e
então o funcionamento dessa organização
foi 2 no início
caracterizada pelo seu funcionamento
democrático
a organização tem uma abrangência e
norma neste momento elas existe ou está
instalada implantada em seis províncias
22 municípios 808 aldeias trabalha com 4
400 associações cerca de 300
cooperativas e no total interage com 250
mil pessoas o que significa quase 11 por
cento da população angolana
eu penso que houve aqui um problema que
devíamos voltar atrás e para falar dos
princípios que presidiram à criação da
organização
o primeiro princípio foi inspirado num
pedagogo uruguaio chamado eduardo
galeano
o homem da utopia moderna não há meta a
meta linha do horizonte nós temos que
não se alcança a linha do horizonte mas
podemos tentar alcançá la
e é nessa medida em que procuramos fazer
o caminho caminhando como diz o poeta
espanhol antonio machado mas também
inspiram nos naquilo que diz um camponês
angolano é perto mas é longe o que
significa que algo pode estar a nossa
estar à mão de semear mas nós temos
sempre de fazer um caminho longo para
atingir os nossos objetivos e voltamos a
eduardo galeano para dizermos que muita
gente pequena em pequenos lugares com
poucos recursos podem ajudar a
transformar o mundo
o contexto da fundação era transição que
estávamos a viver na altura do qual eu
acho destaco a questão da página
estávamos a tentar contribuir para a
construção da paz em angola tinha os
vícios antigos a nossa sociedade é onde
o autoritarismo o servilismo a bajulação
como agora se disseram muito presente
mas também tinham seguranças muito
positivas
a solidariedade agora nós não esquecemos
muito ea nossa trade treaty adicional
abertura ao mundo que vem de séculos e
que se mantém infelizmente até hoje era
uma ambiência em que a fragilidade do
estado era grande e por isso mesmo
muitas vezes agora teve que apanhará
a solução de problemas que na altura
competiam ao estado
agora procurou desde o início uma
abordagem inovadora empreendimento
estratégico planejamento participativo
workshop eram palavras que não se usava
na altura nós pensamos que contribuímos
para a sua introdução no país mas
fundamentalmente o que nós tentamos foi
construir com uma metodologia com base
na integração que gera confiança e essa
confiança que gera capital social e
também capital político mas essas
músicas vinícius que nós procurávamos
nos fizeram esquecer algo que nos parece
fundamental a preservação da identidade
aqui está representada essa idéia da
identidade cultural está representada
por uma instituição que nós prezamos
muito e aqui vale a pena falar um pouco
dela o jango se preferirem em português
a palavra está porto usada o jango
o que é que o que é o jânio não é mais
do que uma reunião em uma reunião que
será realizada também na maneira em que
as pessoas que estão sentadas gensse em
circo ou em simi círculo para poderem
interagir umas com as outras olhando
olhos nos olhos quando nós queremos a
dren começamos a colaborar com amigos de
outros países países mais evoluídos
menos 15 anos atualmente no mundo já não
se usa a disposição das cadeiras com
esta que nós temos aqui agora usa se um
círculo e nós lembramos mas isso já se
usava em angola há 100 ou 200 anos atrás
então vale a pena valorizar esse tipo de
instituição
nós trabalhamos fundamentalmente a adra
trabalha fundamentalmente nas áreas
rurais com aquelas pessoas que nós
considerávamos que eram as que tinham
mais sofrido com a guerra pela via da
economia criando as cooperativas
associações caixa de crédito pela via
cívica política com a cria com a
organização de muitos encontros do vazio
de vários tipo e pela promoção e
capacitação de novas lideranças que
estamos convencidos vão ser muito
proveitosas quando se quando nosso país
se realmente deram os primeiros passos
para a criação do poder autárquico a
promoção do diálogo é fundamental num
país que não estava habituado a isso e
aí o salto
os encontros das comunidades em que
estão presentes representantes das
comunidades com as quais trabalhamos que
interagem com as duas nadadoras mas
também com as autoridades quer
autoridades a nível municipal provincial
e nacional
por exemplo alguns ministros por vezes
estão presentes nesses encontros o
ministro bornito de sousa que está aqui
à minha frente já esteve em dois desses
encontros e atenção não foi fazer a
abertura ele esteve desde o primeiro
minuto até o fim
ouvir essas coisas que as pessoas diziam
as vezes de forma muito frontal
frontalidade é essa que nem sempre
acontece por exemplo quando essas mesmas
pessoas têm de participar nos conselhos
de auscultação e concertação social que
são uma organização do governo e por quê
porque aí os camponeses não se sentem em
casa e sentem exclusivas em ajudar fora
e aí as dificuldades de abertura do
confronto são muito maiores mas o
diálogo também acontece a nível nacional
é é conhecida a atividade da organização
por exemplo na interação com os
ministérios com ano os deputados da
assembleia nacional com organizações
internacionais
estamos a introduzir uma nova linguagem
em angola o fundador de uma doutrina da
província disse há algum tempo quando os
meses depois de ter assumido o lugar do
governador
olha eu quando vou a uma localidade pela
forma como as pessoas se expressam eu
percebo a adra trabalha ou não com
aquela população e isto é porque as
pessoas só falavam com o governador não
exigiam aquela bajulação não vinha
qualquer servilismo olhava pro
governador olhe olhe nos olhos nos olhos
e não menos importante
aprende se a negociar no nosso país
estamos muito habituados a falar em
sentido único o importante é que nós
finalmente começamos a negociar um outro
aspecto que deriva da legitimidade que
nos dá o trabalho realizado a nível do
treino é a possibilidade de influenciar
as políticas públicas são vários os
domínios em que isso acontece como a lei
de terras a própria descentralização do
estado
as zonas de influência pedagógica entre
muitas outras que não têm tempo de ir
além disso faz muitos estudos e análises
procurando colmatar o outro uma outra
deficiência do nosso país está é apenas
um estudo sobre a linha de crédito para
as áreas rurais mas também é conhecido o
trabalho que se faz por exemplo o
orçamento geral do estado que ainda na
semana passada
ouvimos da provisão na rádio falar de um
acontecimento e nos parece extremamente
importante para que as pessoas possam
entender que o orçamento geral do estado
é algo que deve fazer parte do nosso dia
a dia
pra nós que o projeto não é o mais
importante
o mais importante é o processo é forma
como se caminha é um é o caminho que se
faz a caminhar com a luta de todos os
dias à procura da cidadania e e um
exemplo concreto é através do crédito
nós temos vindo a tentar convencer o
governo que o crédito é a melhor forma
que nós
com base na nossa experiência
encontramos para cima para se expressar
e fazer carreira cidadania
as pessoas sentem-se diferentes quando
vão a um banco e para ensinar uma
caderneta de chat se tem mais pessoas
principalmente as mulheres
tudo isso para mim a construção de um
capital social e político que hoje a
adra orgulha se de ter e de funcionar
como uma ponte entre o poder e à
população em geral
perto do fim eu penso que toda esta
actividade que nós temos vindo a relatar
teria de ser complementava com a
globalização ea questão da cidadania é
um belíssimo exemplo de como nós podemos
contribuir a nível global para uma
mudança em tempos em que vivemos há a
questão da da cidadania a recuar em todo
mundo não e principalmente nos países
desenvolvidos onde cada vez mais os
cidadãos vão demitindo da sua da sua do
seu papel de atuarem juntos
do poder pensamos que a cidadania uma
nova utopia que vale a pena procurar por
ela porque a vida ambiente outras coisas
são coisas demasiado importante para
deixarmos apenas nas mãos dos políticos
olhamos para trás e ver e vamos já
procura outra vez de eduardo galeano não
chegamos a linha do horizonte
temos consciência disso mas seguramente
não estamos no mesmo sítio avançamos
muito obrigado